- [Announcer] As an entire
nation buries its head in sand.
- The idea has swept the nation.
But where will we find
enough sand for everyone?
- Now, there are a lot of
weird ideas floating around
out there to do with the coronavirus.
Depending on which dark corner
of the internet you read,
apparently it's anything
from a liberal hoax
to 5G-activated chemtrail smart dust.
More on that one later.
But while most people
aren't falling for anything
quite that ridiculous,
what is driving me nuts
are these bad arguments I keep hearing
that kinda cloak
themselves in rubbish data
and shoddy logic in order
to sound reasonable.
And these arguments are dangerous because
people are falling for
them, and these can have
some very real and severe consequences.
So may I present to you
The Seven Worst Coronavirus Arguments!
(somber music)
I mean sure, I get how
1%, at first glance,
doesn't sound that bad.
And I mean, if we could picture this
as some kind of creepy
COVID-19 Wheel of Fortune,
then yes, the chances of you
getting that unlucky death spin
are very unlikely.
But what I think most
people don't realize is
how this risk stacks up to other things
that we consider typically dangerous.
1% is the same fatality risk
as a full lifetime's worth of driving.
And yet think about how
much money and effort
society has spent on seat
belts, and speed limits,
and speed cameras and so on,
trying to reduce that risk.
But let's go back to our wheel.
Now, people seem to be
forgetting other bad outcomes,
like the risk of permanent lung damage
or a long hospital visit.
Now, let's spin that wheel.
(clacking)
Congratulations, you will be fine.
But now it's time to pass on the wheel
to two of your closest people.
Thank you for playing!
(chimes)
Well, last I checked, old
people are still people.
And, who knows, maybe you
even know an older person
who you don't wish a 10% or
greater chance of death on.
(owl hooting)
Ah yes, so next we have this one
from the self-defeatism camp.
I mean, at first glance,
I get why this seems
all wise and baby Yoda-ish.
I mean, why worry about
what you can't control?
Except for we probably
have SOME kind of agency
over this.
Like, presumably these people agree that
there's some difference between,
say, staying home right now
and flying Wuhan and
getting your bat soup on.
But even if it is already too late,
there are still things
that we can do right now
to reduce how bad it's gonna be.
Our actions over the next few weeks
can decide whether it's a
long but manageable wave
that hits hospitals, or we get
hit by some hellish tsunami
that collapses medical infrastructure
and pushes the risk of
death up for everyone.
(sad horn)
So yes, a similar starting
point to the one before,
but more of a doom-sayer flair.
These are the folks who
also think it's too late,
but also think it's the end of
everything that we hold dear.
Even the mindblowingly
horrible Spanish Flu of 1918,
which infected one in
every three people on earth
and had a higher death rate
still only put a temporary
halt on economic growth,
and society quickly rebounded.
Plus, medicine has improved
quite a lot.
So, stop being silly.
(intense horn)
Oo, now this one drives me mad,
because it doesn't actually
say anything useful.
The word panic is completely subjective.
Like, to some people, it literally means
crying and rocking in the
fetal position in the corner.
And to others, it's
how they would describe
anyone who's expending any extra energy
trying to reduce their
coronavirus risk at all.
(mocking laughter)
So when you do hear someone
making this kinda statement,
make sure to ask them
which specific actions
qualify as panic,
according to the detailed
cost-benefit analysis they
must surely have done.
Because of course, no one would ever
just say this kinda thing to virtue signal
some kind of stoic superiority.
(gentle chimes)
Yes indeed, the numbers
in China are slowing down,
and quite spectacularly, I might add.
I mean, honestly, it's a miracle.
Who could possibly imagine
what could've caused
such a dramatic drop in new cases?
No, but seriously, I
understand why the idea
of having to do any kind of
draconian quarantine measures
sounds terrible, but we've
seen that it clearly works.
So, why people would then try and argue
that we don't need to do them,
because they worked elsewhere,
when it's clearly spreading?
(frustrated groan)
(triumphant music)
So there is this thing called time,
and we don't only care
about previous time,
we also care about upcoming time,
and what is known as the future.
No but seriously, this
coronavirus is brand new,
whereas flu has been around forever,
and it's already endemic around the world.
So it's really unfair to compare
those two numbers so far.
And while I get that exponential growth
is very counterintuitive
and can really make us
underestimate just how fast
these numbers can grow,
the reason why this argument
made my number one spot
is because it's as absurd as if
you're walking down the street
and you notice a bomb drop
out of a plane over your head.
And you're like, "Guys,
quick, take cover!"
And your friend's like,
"Oh shut up your whining,
"it's not killed anyone yet."
So there ya have it.
These are the seven worst
arguments I've heard.
And it's very important we
counter these when we hear them,
because coronavirus is kind of
a self-unfulfilling prophecy.
The more we downplay
it, the worse it'll get.
But if we take it seriously,
we can actually beat it.
So yeah, I guess we
really do just have to do
this annoying social
distancing thing right now,
because it is the only weapon we have
to fight against this damn virus.
And it's kinda weird that
the most social thing
we can be doing is to stay
the hell away from each other.
And on that note, time to
revisit that 5G chemtrail story
I came across on a very dark spiral
I went down on Facebook.
Don't ask about it.
I decided to bring it
to life a little more,
which is I guess what happens
when you don't leave
your house for a week.